SETH LADD: Cool.
All Right.
So if you've joined us, please
mute, and we'll open up for
questions later.
But welcome everybody
who's watching on
air and in the hangout.
This is Dartisans Episode Two.
We have two special guests
today from the Dart team,
Vijay Menon and Anton Muhin.
Hi, guys.
ANTON MUHIN: Hello.
VIJAY MENON: Hello.
SETH LADD: So thanks for
joining us today.
This is really awesome.
Let's get right into it.
Tell everyone who's watching,
and our YouTube friends at
home, what are your roles
on the Dart team?
What are you doing
in these days?
VIJAY MENON: You go
first, Anton?
ANTON MUHIN: OK.
Thank you, Vijay.
So we're working on Dart's
[? room ?], which is home to
Dart VM and to Chromium.
So we can get the best
performance we can provide,
the best developer experience,
and stuff like that.
SETH LADD: So you're working
on integrating the Dart VM
into Chromium.
That sounds pretty exciting.
I know a lot of people are
looking forward to that.
Vijay, what are you working
on these days?
VIJAY MENON: Generally, my
background's compilers,
runtimes, and I've been working
the past while also on
DOM integration, browser
integration, of the Dart
language, the Dart APIs.
And also very closely with Anton
on seeing what it's like
integrating the Dart VM
into the browser.
SETH LADD: Awesome.
Sounds like you have a sweet
spot of background to help the
Dart team out, here.
Anton, what had you been doing
before the Dart team?
ANTON MUHIN: Before the team, I
was engaged into performance
work on the DOM bindings
and on the [? 8th ?]
virtual machine.
Also I had some exposure
to [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
before.
And I really hope this
experience will help us make
the best integration possible.
SETH LADD: I would imagine that
experience on the v8 team
would definitely be relevant
to the Dart team.
What are some of the lessons
that you learned from working
on the v8 team that's helped
you with the Dart project?
ANTON MUHIN: Everything was
minimal [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
matters when you talk about
performance, because sometimes
[? there ?]
[? was ?]
much more to just if you can
remove a couple of comments,
you get the biggest
[? core ?].
So it's an exciting
project, actually.
It's exciting stuff
to work on.
SETH LADD: I know that
performance has always been a
goal of the Dart team,
so that's great.
Well, you guys have been working
really hard today, and
I know we have a special
announcement today.
What are we announcing today?
VIJAY MENON: We're announcing
something?
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] down
in Seattle.
I think that was it, right?
SETH LADD:
That was fast. [LAUGHTER]
VIJAY MENON: Anton, do we have
a special announcement?
ANTON MUHIN: I believe so.
You go ahead, Vijay.
VIJAY MENON: Sure.
Well, you know, any of you
guys who have been paying
attention, or just listen to
what Anton and I work on, know
that we've been working
on integrating the
Dart VM in the browser.
The builds are public, and I
know a few of you brave souls
have actually built it from
our public [? repo. ?]
We've been working on hosting
binaries and making it easier
for you guys to do that.
And I believe Seth could
probably give you the actual
time, but we'll have some
instructions later today, you
think, Seth?
SETH LADD: Yeah.
VIJAY MENON: On exactly how
to download binaries.
Mac and Linux today.
Windows very, very soon.
Fingers crossed.
We're just working on a few
things with the VM team.
But Mac and Linux should be
there today that you can play
around with.
Binaries this time, so you don't
have to actually build
it yourself.
And it's actually just going
to be the output of our
continuous build, so you'll
get the latest
and greatest stuff.
That said, there are
a few things we
want to talk through.
I don't know if it's a good time
to do it, but where we
can give a demo later
on, maybe.
SETH LADD: Yeah, that's
fantastic.
So to reiterate, for everyone
who's just joining us, welcome
to Dartisans Episode Two.
And we have just announced that
we'll be releasing public
binaries of Dartium, which is
Chromium with the Dart virtual
machine integrated into it.
And we'll make these binaries
available later
today on our website.
This is huge news.
This is another step forward
for our batteries included
Dart platform.
When we announced and launched
last October, we had a virtual
machine, language spec, early
revision, libraries, and now
finally, moving closer to this
batteries included idea by
putting Dart VM into Chromium.
So this is great news.
Thanks, guys.
Can you talk a little bit about
what it actually means
to integrate Dart
with Chromium?
I mean, exactly what
did you do?
VIJAY MENON: As you heard from
Anton, he worked before on
putting v8s into the browser.
And this is kind of another
exercise in doing that.
Embedding the VM itself in the
browser means kind of drilling
all the holes through, getting
all of the DOM integration so
that you can actually interact
with the browser's DOM from
the Dart language.
Integrating it with things like
developer tools, adding
the support for the MIME
types, and so on.
Doing a lot of performance
work.
So there's quite a bit to it.
Chrome is a big beast, and
figuring out how to get this
to work, and work alongside the
v8s has kind of been the
main challenge.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SETH LADD: Go ahead, Anton.
ANTON MUHIN: Sorry.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
cases you should be aware of,
because all this stuff,
something like when you upload,
[? you just ?] see
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
[? collect ?]
some stuff, and how the API
should behave, how the
application should be started,
how you can then [? upload ?]
application.
There's a lot of difficult
and [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
we have addressed, we
hope to address.
And we wanted to explore, and
ideally to provide the best
environment for the
applications.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
SETH LADD: So if the Dart
virtual machine is now
directly inside Chromium, that
means I can run Dart code
straight up in Chromium.
But what about other browsers?
What do we have answers
for those?
VIJAY MENON: Well, compiling
to JavaScript using the
Dart-to-JavaScript compiler
is still very, very
important to Dart.
That's how you will get it to
run on other, modern browsers.
And to emphasize, it's not
in Chromium proper.
It's in our branch of Chromium
that we're calling Dartium.
This is very much a development
tool that we're
working on and experimenting.
It is work in progress.
Those of you who really use it
will know that you're really
using it when you managed to
get an "Aw, snap" screen in
Chrome, and so on.
So very much work in progress.
We're trying to prove to
ourselves and everyone else
that having native Dart support
in the browser is a
good thing, and we're hoping
for feedback on that.
I think that's kind of the
point we're at right now.
Early feedback is if
people like this
for development purposes.
They love the ability to be able
to just edit their Dart
code and just reload in the
browser and see it working.
And as we go forward, the VM
team is working really hard on
performance.
We're working closely with
them on performance with
respect to rendering
in the browser.
And you should see
a lot of those
improvements coming along.
So we're looking for feedback
to see, does this make the
experience better, both with
developing Dart applications
and running Dart applications,
and I think we go from there.
Improve it in Chrome first.
SETH LADD: That's an
excellent point.
This is very much a technology
preview.
Along with the whole Dart
project, which is still in
technology preview as we add
features to the language, we
smooth out the libraries, and
launch this stuff very early,
so as you say, get feedback
from developers.
How can developers give
us their feedback?
Any recommendations there?
VIJAY MENON: Tell us what works,
what doesn't work.
In particular, file bugs.
It's a lot of the things people
have been doing with
the Dart language and so on.
A lot of these things are
just coming live.
Developer tools, support.
There's some preliminary
stuff in there.
It's going to continue
improving.
Give us feedback on what works,
what doesn't work.
When things crash, please
file bugs on us.
If things don't work, please
That's a big reason why this
is going out early.
ANTON MUHIN: And just
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
We are really looking
for feedback.
We just did a couple of
decisions when implementing
Dart, Dartium, and in
some cases, we just
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
We really hope to get feedback
from people who do web
application programming so we
can revisit our old decisions
and make things more
convenient, more
easy for you to use.
So we're really, really looking
for your feedback.
SETH LADD: So specifically, if
you want to send us bugs and
issues, please do
at dartbug.com.
That's a nice shortcut to get
to our issue tracker.
So that's dartbug.com.
And on dartlang.org, you'll see
links to our mailing list
where there's lots of active
discussion, and many of our
Dart team participate there.
So lots of different ways to
send us your feedback.
We launched this stuff early
in developer preview
specifically to get
your feedback, so
please don't be shy.
For everyone who's joining us,
this is Dartisans Episode Two,
with special guest from
the Dart team.
We've just announced the
binaries of Dart VM integrated
into Chromium will be available
later today for download.
And we'll take questions for
everyone, so please add
questions to our Google+ posts
if you're not joining us in
the hangout, and we will route
those into our guests.
In fact, we already got a
question here from Google+.
John asks, why is it that the
Dart support was shipped into
a separate build of Chromium
in the first place, rather
than just shipping it into
the Chromium builds?
ANTON MUHIN: The reason
is actually simple.
Dart is complicated and
very big system.
Dart [? and ?]
[? the ?]
[? bindings ?].
And we don't [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
right now, but we have all
these resources out.
So we don't want to compromise
stability, the ability of
Chrome, its current stage of
development of Dartium
integration, but we are really
aiming for that later on.
So when we think we're in better
shape, and we don't
provide any security risk,
and instability risk, any
slowdowns from Chrome when we
don't compromise on any point,
we'll call to have Dart
integrated into Chrome.
VIJAY MENON: And to follow up
on that point, I want to
emphasize that this is
a developer release.
Please don't use this for
day-to-day browsing.
As Anton said, this hasn't gone
through the stringent
security that we do this
with Chrome builds.
It doesn't autoupdate.
And we basically set these
things to expire in about a
week or two, so we want
you to download--
this is, again, early.
We need to get it more stable
before we can get this into
Chromium proper, or
Chrome proper.
SETH LADD: And I think the
question everyone's asking is
where can developers get this?
We will post links of this on
dartlang.org later today, and
it'll be real easy for you to go
and download, just like you
can download the Editor,
et cetera.
So just watch for dartlang.org
later today, where you can get
your hands on this.
This is cool stuff.
And Vijay, you answered
the other question.
Will it be automatically
updated?
I think you said the answer is
no, this is not our normal
Chrome or Chromium channel.
This is a standalone, kind
of snapshot build.
Is that the right way
to think about that?
VIJAY MENON: Right.
Right.
SETH LADD: So now that we have
the Dart virtual machine
inside a build of Chromium,
can developers run both
JavaScript and Dart
on the same page?
VIJAY MENON: Yes, they can.
That's one of those things that
Anton talked about it.
Right now, you can't invoke one
directly from the other.
And that's probably going to
stay that way because of a lot
of the technical issues
involved.
The way you can communicate
with--
there'll probably a couple
different ways you can
communicate between JavaScript
and Dart.
First of all, JavaScript and
Dart are essentially isolated
from each other on the page.
They can communicate
via the DOM.
They can communicate via
things like post
message on a window.
You can add a handler in Dart,
and you can send messages to
it from JavaScript,
and vice versa.
ANTON MUHIN: And ideally
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
ideally will prefer if you don't
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] the
same DOM tree from both
Dart and JavaStream
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
pretty complicated and just
[? kernel ?] cases.
So [? new ?] for communicating
between Dart [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
you have an I frame or have just
a subtree of DOM, and you
just communicate with something
like post message
[? router. ?]
Just as a model of Dart, we
hope [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
to communication
of JavaScript.
SETH LADD: So it sounds like
the recommendation is, use
post message right now to
communicate between your
JavaScript code and
your Dart code.
VIJAY MENON: Yes.
ANTON MUHIN: But you can have
use cases when you want to
modify the same DOM directory.
Please let us know, because we
are really looking for your
feedback for your experience,
for your needs.
SETH LADD: So what it sounds
like, it is possible today to
manipulate the same DOM with
both JavaScript and Dart, but
that could get you
into trouble?
ANTON MUHIN: It's very unlikely,
but probably yes.
VIJAY MENON: Well, yeah.
You can put Dart scripts and you
can put JavaScript scripts
on the same page.
They can both manipulate
the DOM.
It's our intent to make that
work perfectly well.
But today, expect to see some
funky behavior, and if you do,
let us know about it.
And there's certainly still some
technical challenges we
have to solve there with
essentially garbage
collection, making sure things
don't leak, get a little
complicated when you have two
runtimes in the browser.
SETH LADD: It sounds like the
expectation then is once we
get the kinks ironed out, you
should be able to have both
scripts operating is it more
or less concurrently?
Are they running
in the separate
processes or separate threads?
Or how would you characterize
Dart and
JavaScript parallel execution?
ANTON MUHIN: This is just a
common DOM model when you have
the same stuff running on
the main UI thread.
So you run a JavaScript
for some time.
When you yield, then you run
Dart script for some time, you
yield, and so on.
So nothing will change
dramatically here.
Of course, if you don't use
something like isolates or
[? workers, ?] stuff which adds
real multithreading into
both Dart and JavaScript.
VIJAY MENON: Yeah, they do run
in the same process, and
that's actually pretty
important to getting
performance.
That's why Dart is very
different from, say, a
plug-in, where if you look at
plug-ins-- like, say, the Java
plug-in or others-- they
typically don't interact that
tightly with the DOM.
They live in their own window.
In order to really write apps
that interact very closely
with the DOM, you really need
to be running on the same
process, tightly coupled with
the UI of the browser.
And so Dart really sits right
next to v8 in our builds, the
JavaScript engine.
SETH LADD: So John asks
a good question.
Can you clarify, do the
individual Dart script tags,
are they all running on
the same UI thread?
ANTON MUHIN: Yes.
But in different isolates.
For each script tag, you have
this on a separate isolate,
and involve on all those
isolates from [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
the main UI thread
of the browser.
SETH LADD: So if each script is
running in its own isolate,
does that mean each script then
is required to have a
main function?
ANTON MUHIN: Yes.
VIJAY MENON: That's correct.
SETH LADD: Can you just
spend a minute
talking about isolates?
This is kind of a new
concept if your
're JavaScript developer.
What does that mean
each script is
running in an isolate?
ANTON MUHIN: An isolate is just
a unit concurrency in
Dart, just unit [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
It's roughly a thread
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
So it's instance of
the [? image ?]
as a separate heap, so we can
ensure references between
different [? isolates ?].
And it executes on its own,
but it doesn't always
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
some [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
system thread.
As we talked just a couple of
minutes ago, some isolates are
multiplexed on the
same thread.
And we'll probably
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
support for [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
and stuff like that.
And to some extent, isolates
are close to current
JavaScript [? workers ?]
but they're supposed to
be more lightweight
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
but [? workers ?]
should be heavyweight.
We expect isolates to be pretty
much lightweight and
just roughly [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
formalize it.
VIJAY MENON: To follow up on
the green thread point, so
different script tags run
different in isolates.
Any isolates that can interact
with the DOM all
run on the UI thread.
They're all multiplexed onto
that same UI thread.
So it is really like a sandbox
unit that in some cases can
run on background threads if
they don't touch the DOM.
And we went with that model
for better security.
We think we can build more
secure apps that way.
Script injection's less of an
issue because Dart scripts,
even if you inject a Dart script
into a page, you can't
directly interact with other
Dart scripts that
you have on the page.
SETH LADD: Which I think
is a very important
clarification, right?
So you can potentially have
multiple script tags, each
loading up a Dart file which
has a main function.
Each one of those is running
in an isolate.
If that Dart script touches or
manipulates the DOM, it will
run in the same UI thread, but
it's still isolated in the
sense that one Dart script
doesn't know about the other
Dart script.
Is that true?
VIJAY MENON: Yeah.
It's somewhat similar to what
we were just talking about a
few minutes ago about Dart to
JavaScript communication.
Again, two Dart isolates on the
same page, two Dart script
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] tags on the
same page, can again
communicate via post message.
But they can't directly reach
into each other's heap.
SETH LADD: Got it.
How does Dartium know if
a script does or will
manipulate the DOM?
Do you look through
the API calls as
you compile the script?
ANTON MUHIN: [UNINTELLIGIBLE] we
apply a pretty simple rule
If you have script tag in the
page, [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
manipulate DOM.
And currently [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
API to spawn [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
dominated isolates versus
just plain isolates.
So roughly in API with the
special call, we say, I want
to create a new isolate,
but I want this
isolate to have DOM access.
Which means that this isolate
will run on plain UI thread.
Or we say, I want to say it will
spawn in our isolate, and
I don't care about
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
And in this case, you have the
liberty to put it on any
thread which you find
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
convenient for us.
VIJAY MENON: Yeah.
The isolate API is definitely
under a lot of
iteration right now.
Today, the declarative
script tags are run
on the same UI thread.
You have to programmatically
create isolates that run on
background threads.
SETH LADD: I see, OK.
And I think that if you're
familiar with Dart has light
and heavy isolates.
And a heavy isolate, at least
when compiled to JavaScript,
will go to a web worker.
But if you have a heavy isolate
running inside of the
Dart VM in Dartium, that will
just spawn a separate--
it doesn't go to web
worker, right?
It just goes to a heavy isolate
inside the virtual
machine, I would imagine.
ANTON MUHIN: Yes.
But once again, that's a very
[? messy ?] topic for us,
what's the best way to divide
the space between isolates and
workers, because both has its
benefits, and to some extent,
both are pretty close
concepts.
Once again, if that is
[? good ?] for us, and this is
the area of [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
research.
SETH LADD: OK.
So it sounds like we're
definitely asking the
developer community, play with
heavy and light isolates, play
with multiple script tags, and
give us some good use cases
and feedback on how
all this works.
ANTON MUHIN: That would
be just awesome.
SETH LADD: OK.
So do I need to do anything
special to activate Dart on my
pages here?
Or is just a simple script tag,
is that all it takes?
VIJAY MENON: So we iterated
on this quite a bit.
Part of the trickiness is just
getting it integrated into
Chrome and WebKit, and
figuring out what
the right hooks are.
With the binaries that are
released today, you won't have
to do anything.
If you just have a script with
the type application Dart, it
will go ahead and run.
Those of you who have built it
in the past few weeks have
noticed that we changed
this a few times.
We had a function that we were
using from JavaScript to
bootstrap it.
If you look under the hood,
that's still there.
We just have a way of just
invoking that for you, so you
don't actually have to
put it on your page.
And I'll show you an example
later if have
some time to demo.
SETH LADD: Yeah, that's
an excellent segue.
And for everyone joining us,
this is Dartisans Episode Two.
We have special guests
from the Dart team.
Today we've announced that
binaries of Chromium plus Dart
VM integration will be made
available later today on
dartlang.org.
And for everyone following along
via the live stream,
please add your questions and
comments to the G+ feed.
We'll be monitoring those, and
we'll ask those questions to
our panel here.
But yeah, I think
it's fantastic.
Let's see a example.
Can you show us a Dart program
running in Dartium?
What does that look like?
VIJAY MENON: OK.
Let me try to share
my copy here.
OK, is that showing up?
SETH LADD: Yeah, looks good.
VIJAY MENON: OK.
So this is Dartium.
You can tell it's the Mac by
the boundaries and so on.
So as we were saying earlier,
this is the
development tool right now.
Before I launch into anything,
I just want to emphasize
what's in red here.
This is technical preview.
Don't use this as your
primary browser.
It hasn't gone through all the
deep security review that we
do for, say, production Chrome,
and not even as much
as, say, the Chromium that you
get from the dev channel.
So this is very preliminary
stuff.
It's great for testing
your Dart apps.
Don't go off, read your mail, go
to news sites, or whatever
on this, because it hasn't
been secured.
So that said, we wanted to do
a few of those things to
integrate those in there
to help developers.
One is that we wanted the start
page just to emphasize
this point.
This is the home page
when you launch.
It will give you information
on Dartium.
So let's get to the
meat of it.
As we said, the interesting
thing here is being able to
run Dart applications.
And here's a very simple example
of a Dart app, a
test.html that I've got here
that's just got a script, an
application Dart script,
in my bin.
Its importing the HTML library,
and it's basically
running hello from Dart
and adding that to
the body of the document.
And you can see that
running here.
So again, this is pretty
short and sweet.
Nothing really to it.
It's creating an element,
adding it to the body.
There's nothing that you
need to bootstrap it.
Just you will see the
application Dart, and as we
reload it, it's there.
We can also run larger apps.
This is a test version
of Swarm.
It's a newsreader that
we've demoed before.
This is really what's
just in the source.
It's not showing any articles.
But this is all running
in the Dart runtime.
If you've seen it demoed
before, you've seen it
compiled to JavaScript.
So we think cool things about it
when you run it in the Dart
VM, is that you get
the console here.
You can look at all
of the scripts.
So this is an application that
has some 60 Dart files to it.
They all just show up in
the dev tools thing.
As you make changes, you can
just reload it, and it will
just reload it in the browser.
So we really think that'll
be cool for
the development cycle.
And this stuff just started
coming up in
the past couple weeks.
Pavel, one of our colleagues in
Saint Petersburg, has just
added a lot of support
for dev tools.
Here I've set a break point
on the onload thing.
So if I go ahead and
I reload the page,
you can see it break.
Let's see.
He's just changing
what you can see.
So again, much incentive
to keep updating this.
You'll see more and more
cool stuff here.
ANTON MUHIN: Tomorrow, the day
after tomorrow, we should be
able to inspect your frames.
So it will be closer to full
fledged [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
VIJAY MENON: Right.
So here you can see, you can
already set break points and
continue on from there.
So I think this will be pretty
cool to use for writing large
Dart applications.
Even if you intend to compile
it to JavaScript, this is a
very nice way of developing.
And you get the native
Dart runtime support.
We really like the dev
experience, and that's the
feedback we've gotten
to there.
SETH LADD: That's a
good point, Vijay.
To reiterate, I think if
anything, Dartium just really
makes an awesome
dev experience.
You can think of, you're coding
in the editor, you're
getting syntax highlighting,
you're getting code
completion.
And you can run that Dart code
straight inside Dartium.
Zero compilation step, there.
Test your app.
And then when you go to
production, you can compile to
JavaScript and hit every
major browser.
So if anything, Dartium enables
us to move just as
fast as other web developers
with no compilation.
I think that's just fantastic.
ANTON MUHIN: And [? develop ?]
feature we expect to be
implemented pretty soon.
Something like in a couple of
weeks, so we want to have
better integration between
Dart editor and Dartium.
So you will be able to debug the
code in Dartium from your
Dart editor [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
So we hope that it will
help you as well.
SETH LADD: That's an
excellent point.
I'm looking forward to that.
VIJAY MENON: And one other thing
I want to show up here.
You'll notice this Dart
tool tip here.
The icon's probably a little
hard to see over there.
We've integrated this kind of
playground here that we found
really useful for testing
out stuff.
This is sort of analogous to the
Dartboard app if you used
it on Dartlang, except it's
actually just running locally.
There's no server
involved here.
It's just running.
And of course, it's also running
on the VM, so it gives
you a chance to see what
works on the VM, what
doesn't work on the VM.
As you find problems with APIs
or stuff like that, this is
also a great way to test
something out, send us an
email saying, hey, I tried this
in the playground and it
didn't work.
So basically, this is
stuff you can go
ahead and edit here.
"Hello from Dart today." And it
just goes ahead and runs.
And you can play around
with that.
The other thing here is that you
can look at the console,
and you can get error
messages.
So print also just prints
the console.
It's like console.log, for
those of you who are
familiar with that.
Let me see if I can go
ahead and open that.
You can see that, open the dev
tools console to see this just
printed out, when we went
and clicked on run.
Let me try that more time,
you'll see the message appear
one more time.
So again, it's a really easy
way, even if you're not really
interested in the browser, you
just want to play around with
what can VM do, what are the
semantics of this or that,
play around with the language.
The playground is really
handy for that.
And error messages
will improve.
But here, let me just take
out this quote here.
So I've got a badly formed
program, and you see the error
message here.
Unterminated string literal,
line 3, position 43.
Again, that can be improved, but
you get the messages that
can really help you see
what's going on.
And as you load your Dart apps
to- if you have a syntax
error, just open the console.
You'll see the errors
from the VM show
up here on the console.
SETH LADD: That is so cool.
VIJAY MENON: I can go
ahead and fix that.
We'll see that running again.
OK.
So anything else you want
to show, Anton?
ANTON MUHIN: Probably not.
VIJAY MENON: I'll just
add one thing Anton
actually just added in.
Let's see if this works.
ANTON MUHIN: I think it's
Chrome version.
VIJAY MENON: I think I actually
went to this thing.
But yeah, another thing is you
can see the version of the
Dart VM that's integrated here
now, as well, along with
everything else.
As you do report issues or run
into issues, please let us
know what version number you've
got, and that will help
us reproduce things
and fix stuff.
SETH LADD: It would be very cool
if in the console, you
could have "report this bug."
VIJAY MENON: Yeah.
Yeah.
We've talked about that.
Especially with the playground,
it's just such a
nice way of writing test cases
that are small, and say, yeah,
this API doesn't work.
Seth, you've been following a
lot of bugs lately in the past
week, so you know it's a nice-
SETH LADD: I don't
call them bugs.
I call them opportunities.
VIJAY MENON: Opportunities.
You've been sharing many
opportunities with us, with
the team recently.
So, yes.
SETH LADD: I have a couple
questions about how this fits
into the other features of
the Dart virtual machine.
For one, Dart can run in two
different execution modes,
production and checked.
Production mode will run with
the type assertions turned
off, and check mode will turn
on those type assertions.
Oftentimes, check mode is very
useful during the debugging
cycle and the authoring cycle.
How do I toggle between
these two
different modes in Dartium?
VIJAY MENON: You want to
take that one, Anton?
ANTON MUHIN: OK, if
you don't mind.
So for now, it's not
very convenient.
For now, we have to provide
a special--
when you start Dartium, you only
provide [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
just environment variable
which [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
flags and enables
checkit mode.
For example, enable
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
We are going to open that, and
eventually want to expose
somewhat APIs so that we can
control this setting in more
convenient way.
And we hope to publish a tiny
article, just maybe a page,
maybe even less, how to enable
those [? checks ?]
later when Dartium release
will go official.
SETH LADD: Right.
We will publish those
when we publish the
how to download Dartium.
So we'll include the instruction
how to flip
between these two modes.
Do you think we'll eventually
put those into about:flags?
ANTON MUHIN: Maybe, maybe just.
We definitely have one
option we have discussing
something like that.
You can switch this mode on
directly from the Dart.
So something like you start the
Dart application, and you
say, on check mode, something
like that.
We are really discussing
it these days.
It's another thing
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
VIJAY MENON: Yeah, we definitely
want to make it
easy to run check mode.
By default, it's off, as
you can see if this
example is still up.
I just said, [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
message equals a string here,
and you can see it's still
running just fine here, and
printing it out.
That's because we're running
in production mode.
If you do run it in check
notice, as Anton said--
today you have to use a set
environment flag to do that--
then you would see an error on
the console saying that the
type check fails.
In check mode, you'd have
a type check on
that line right there.
ANTON MUHIN: On the good side,
when we have is planned
integration with Dart editor,
Dart editor should be able to
start Dartium for you with all
the flags properly set.
So in development mode, you will
have this check mode for
free, and you won't have to
default with nested flags,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] and
stuff like that.
VIJAY MENON: Yeah, that's a good
reason to use the editor.
I think they already have the
support in there to fire off
in dev mode, and I highly
recommend it for
development of apps.
It will run slower, but when
you're trying to find bugs,
it's great to have this check
here and catch this.
Presumably you put
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
message, because you want to
actually convey something.
And you will get that
check in check mode.
SETH LADD: So Vijay, you can
flip back to you and
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
Awesome, hi.
So John asks another
good question.
Another feature of the
Dart ecosystem is
the support of snapshots.
Snapshots allow you to take a
snapshot or kind of a binary
[? serialization ?]
of the heap of the
program right
before it starts executing.
This we've seen in our internal
test really speeds up
initialization of the program.
Is this something that Dartium
supports today, snapshots?
And if not, what's
the plan there?
ANTON MUHIN: Oh, yes, we do some
support snapshots, which
really supports two kinds
of snapshots.
So the first snapshot
allows you--
once again, in Dart everything
is an isolate.
So we have a very fast way to
start an isolate from a
snapshot, which loads all the
libraries you have to use.
And that gives us a quite
reasonable startup time for
the application, and still
want to improve upon it.
Dartium supports now an
interesting feature.
It's only partial application
snapshot, which allows you to
make binary representation of
the application, which it
starts on top of
the libraries.
And we have experimental support
in Dartium for caching
of these partial snapshots.
So roughly, if you have a
huge application, you
would start it once.
Program is able to cache this
binary [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
application.
And next time you will open
this Dart application, it
starts even faster, because
you're starting
directly from snapshots.
This is an experimental feature,
because it might have
security implications.
We had some interesting
discussions about caching
policies of this partial
snapshot, because
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
normal web case, server can
tell you how long you're
allowed to cache
this resource.
But [UNINTELLIGIBLE] application
consist many
parts, so we need to devise a
reasonable policy for caching
partial snapshots.
But we really hope to have
something like that
eventually, because one of our
goals is absolutely blazing
startup time for your [? old ?]
applications.
SETH LADD: So this application
snapshot experimental feature,
it sounds like that's actually
here today, and we as
developers will be able
experience this much faster
startup time on the
second load.
Is that something we should
explicitly test for you and
send feedback on?
ANTON MUHIN: If you please.
Right now, in the current build
of Dartium, it will only
work for you if you reload the
application in the same tab
due to technical difficulties.
Later, we can expose it,
for example, under the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] so we can
switch it on and off to
experimental test.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
we will just [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
VIJAY MENON: Also today, if
you turn it on, it won't
interact very well with dev
tools, because of course,
there's some tricks.
Dev tools likes to work off the
actual scripts, and the
snapshot actually doesn't
need the scripts.
So that bridge will be closed
too, so there's still some
things to clean up there to make
it really easy to use.
But yeah, an app like Swarm, I'm
pretty excited to see what
we do with snapshot.
As we saw, there were like 60
different files that write.
So being able to have the
snapshot just cache that in
the browser and restart from
that I think will be great as
we deploy these applications.
SETH LADD: I'm really excited
for this feature, actually.
I agree improving startup time
has always been an important
goal of the Dart project, and I
think snapshots are going to
help tremendously here.
VIJAY MENON: To follow up
Anton's point about there
being two levels of snapshot.
So things like dart:dom,
dart:core, dart:html, those
are all part of a snapshot that
you're getting for free.
So we're actually starting
from the snapshot that's
already defined all those things
in there, and that's
why we can have a bigger library
there, which are
library for Dart and
not pay so much for
it at startup time.
SETH LADD: So if I write a
random Dart script-- like you
had the "Hello world"
example there--
and an imported dart:html.
Does that mean when the Dart
virtual machine inside
Dartium, loads up your "Hello
world" simple, three-line
script, it's already
starting from a
snapshotted version of dart:html?
ANTON MUHIN: Yes.
SETH LADD: That's pretty
impressive.
Let's take some questions from
the Google+ stream here.
Alan asks, is there an API
into the operating system
environment settings
from within Dart?
And I can't tell if this is
specific to Dartium or not.
ANTON MUHIN: Exposing API, which
can access operating
system services from the
browser, sounds like
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
due to various security
considerations.
So we are not aiming to provide
any additional API
than just a typical browser
already has implemented in
JavaScript.
But if you're [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
have a use case, maybe the
better way would be, for
example, to improve on file
API in the browser.
VIJAY MENON: Yeah.
I mean, in terms of the
operating system capabilities
or other environment
capabilities, we're not
looking to add anything new to
Dart that you can't do in
JavaScript.
We really want to get
that from HTML5.
HTML5 is starting to add more
and more cool stuff that lets
you have local storage.
I think particularly for mobile
devices, there's all
kinds of cool stuff
you can get.
And our goal is to really
expose that in Dart,
not drill new holes.
You really want to be careful
about providing access to that
sort of stuff so you can do
it in a very secure way.
SETH LADD: That's an
excellent point.
I think it's important to
reiterate that the Dart inside
the browser effort, we're
following all the lessons
learned, all the best practices,
all the security
reviews, eventually, that the
JavaScript world has pioneered
for many, many years.
That is, we're operating on the
same types of constraints
that any other scripting
language, like JavaScript
inside the browser.
And that's very important
for us to do.
I think to answer Alan's
question, though, from the
server side, Dart does work
on the server as well.
And nothing we're doing with
the language design or
libraries paints us into any
kind of corner for just client
side web apps.
So I believe on the server side,
it would be interesting
to be able to find the system
OS environments.
We already have server side
support for opening socket,
server side support for reading
files off the native
operating system file system.
So Dart is definitely being
designed holistically to be an
end-to-end solution,
server and client.
But these kind of questions
about operating environment
settings, as Vijay and Anton
mentioned, that would really
only apply to running on the
command line over on the
server side.
VIJAY MENON: Yeah.
One thing that's cool about that
is there'll be libraries
that will let you access
that on the server.
So I think dart:io, I haven't
played around with it much,
but that has a lot of the sort
of stuff you'd want on a
server to access the local
file system and such.
And that library will not be
available in the browser,
because we're not going to give
you the ability to just
go mess around with the
user's file system.
SETH LADD: You're operating in
the same kind of sandbox
security environment that any
other JavaScript file would be
running in, which is
very important.
Mark from the Google+ stream
asks, will Dart eventually be
submitted for standardization
by a body outside Google, or
will it continue to be primarily
a Google technology?
I'm interested in Dart, but
not in learning a Google
version of VB scripts.
What's our general
philosophy there?
VIJAY MENON: I don't know
what the timeline for
that is going to be.
I'm not probably the best
person to answer that.
You'd probably give as
good of an answer on
that as I could, Seth.
But I think eventually, sure.
I couldn't really comment
on what the--
SETH LADD: Yeah.
I think that eventually
standardization makes a lot of
sense, especially as we target
Dart for the entire open
modern web.
But we think it's very early to
talk about that, and right
now we just need to get to a
1.0, get to some sort of a
shipable production-ready
version.
And I think only then does it
make sense for us to begin the
standardization process.
I do want to be clear about this
comparison of VB script.
I don't think that's
entirely very fair.
Dart has been open source ever
since our initial technology
preview launch back
in October.
And it has always been
compilable to JavaScript, and
it will always be compilable
to JavaScript.
And so, Dart is very much
aimed, since day one,
explicitly at the entire
open modern web.
So I think it's a way to
encourage developers from all
different app platforms to
develop and deliver fantastic,
complex, engaging apps
for modern web.
And to do that, we'll always
have to compile the
JavaScript.
So I don't think the
comparison of VB
script is very fair.
Let's see.
Jay from the Google+ stream
says, regarding check mode,
has there been any discussion
about using check mode checks
to report code coverage?
Since all checks happen at
runtime, they don't do any
good if they're not being hit.
Reporting number of checks that
are never executed would
be a great quantitative
testing tool.
ANTON MUHIN: We really hope
that Dart will have
[? great ?] tools eventually
which will make
developer life easier.
And we [? could ?]
have something [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
as well [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
which we use currently for
checks, can be used to produce
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
I don't think it will come in
just a couple of weeks, but
eventually we want to provide
the best development
experience we can.
SETH LADD: So we have about
10 minutes left.
So if you want to get
your questions in,
please join to hangout.
There is room here.
Or post to the Google+ stream.
For those who are going to
download Dartium later today
and start testing this out,
are there any caveats they
should be aware of other than,
of course, this technology
preview, and please don't use
it for day-to-day browsing.
But for instance, does it create
its own profile, or
does it use the existing profile
of their currently
installed Chrome or Chromium?
VIJAY MENON: You want
to take that, Anton?
ANTON MUHIN: If you
don't mind.
I think just to say,
once again, Dartium
is the project preview.
So we would really recommend
you to create a separate
profile for Dartium, because
you probably don't want
Dartium to mess up with all
your bookmarks and your
personal stuff [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
profiles.
So it's just a sanity measure
to keep your regular Chrome,
if you have Chrome
as your regular
browser, and Dartium separate.
VIJAY MENON: If you're running
regular Chrome--
not Chromium, but Chrome--
alongside Dartium, and Dartium
is the only-- you're not
running Chromium, it should
just by default have a
separate profile.
But if you do use Chromium for
some other reason, you have
two different Chromium
builds, they will
trample on each other.
ANTON MUHIN: And we will provide
guidelines in the
Dartium documentation
how to use a
separate profile for you.
SETH LADD: That's right.
We'll include in the
documentation we'll release
later today how to set up your
own profile directory so you
don't trample on other existing
compound Chromiums.
That's why it's usually great
for testing, too.
You can blow away the specific
profile if you need to start
fresh, and you don't mess
with anything else.
So, absolutely.
So let's take another question
here from the G+ stream.
Are there any difficulties you
face as a developer when you
develop Dart because it needs
to compile to JavaScript?
Is there anything that will
become impossible to compile
the JavaScript?
VIJAY MENON: That's a really
good question.
It's certainly not our intent.
I mean, as Seth said earlier,
compiling the JavaScript is
very, very important and
will be important for
a long, long time.
So Dart, I mean, in my view is
one of the reasons why we have
a new language here, is that we
wanted to create something
that you could compile pretty
faithfully down to JavaScript,
but still you gave a better
developer experience.
So I think for the foreseeable
future, I don't see anything
where you wouldn't be able
to run it on JavaScript.
I think down the line, you'll
get benefits running natively
as Dart because you get better
performance, better startup,
check mode, stronger
checks, and so on.
But your apps should run in
JavaScript, absolutely.
SETH LADD: I should probably
add that through some of my
experimentation, there are very
corner cases we still
have to work out to be
totally transparent.
For instance, Dart, its
integers are arbitrary
precision, for instance.
You can just bang on your
keyboard all day for an
integer, and Dart will go
ahead and suck that in.
But when you compile that to
JavaScript, JavaScript has
limits on integer precision.
So there is a slight
disconnect there.
There's some open bugs there, if
you're curious about that.
And so, this is why we launch,
I think, in technology
preview, too, right?
We want real developers to test
this out, and help us,
first, identify these corner
cases, and then help us
understand what it is that they
want the system to do in
these kind of cases, as well.
But generally, as Vijay said,
the intent is to be able to
compile to logical, same
performance JavaScript, and
that's a core tenet of the
language, absolutely.
ANTON MUHIN: And for example, we
have a huge pile of tests,
and we run both [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
Dart VM, Dartium and compile
to JavaScript code.
And we try to minimize the
difference between the results
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] absolute
possible minimum.
SETH LADD: So as we wrap
up here, what's
next for you guys?
What's the next couple weeks or
months look like for you in
the Dart team?
Vijay?
VIJAY MENON: Sure.
Well, we're going to
make things better.
Dev tools, you're going to be
seeing big changes there over
the next few days, actually.
I think Pavel's got some changes
coming in that will
help stuff.
Anton said--
I talked about snapshotting
as something he's been
working on a lot.
Isolate APIs.
Also dart:html is something
under active development as
well, and basically we're
working to make sure you get
the same experience on both the
JavaScript path and the
Dartium path.
But sometimes one runs ahead
of the other, but we're
actually using a lot of the same
scripts now to generate
the implementations for both
to keep those things
consistent.
So a lot of improvement
on APIs, a lot of
improvements on dev tools.
We're doing a lot of performance
testing right now.
We just really started
on that.
So a lot of things that Anton
alluded to the very beginning.
He did a lot of work on v8,
which is a fantastic
experience.
He knows where a lot of
the problem areas are.
But we're just starting
to benchmark,
hammering on the DOM.
And we got a ways to go there,
but we fully intend to make
that very fast and yet
consistent between Dartium and
compilation to JavaScript
as well.
SETH LADD: Anton, anything
to add there?
What's next for you with Dart?
ANTON MUHIN: Just one
important thing.
We are not complete on the API
implementation because in some
cases we had to take shortcuts
just because we don't have
enough hands.
We are going to improve
our [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
APIs, especially some
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
APIs.
And that would be a constant
goal for us, I think, at least
for a couple of months
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
SETH LADD: I think you bring
up an excellent point.
A lot of Dart isn't done yet.
We're still in technology
preview.
So the main ask for our
developers out there is please
do try all these different
aspects of the Dart platform.
The editor, the language, the
libraries, the virtual
machine, the JavaScript
compiler, and now Dartium.
And please do join the mailing
list. Please do file new
issues, dartbug.com.
We definitely listen to
all this feedback.
Our team is very well-engaged
and listening to
what's going on.
So please do try it all
out, and let us know.
And it looks like one more
question, because I know this
comes up a lot, from John.
So reflection, our mirror-based
reflection API.
Do we have any ideas?
Is this weeks, or months,
or years away?
VIJAY MENON: I don't know,
actually, to be honest. Not
weeks, but I know it's being
actively worked on.
I don't know what the timeline
for that coming out is.
SETH LADD: Yeah, I get the sense
that this is a large
implementation effort than maybe
some other, just like,
pure library features.
And so I do know that it's very,
very close on the radar,
and there's active discussion
to work on it.
But yeah, we're not exactly
sure what any kind
of timeline is there.
But definitely we'll be
delivering a mirror-based API
at some point for us
to experiment with.
Well, I want to thank everybody
for joining us for
Episode Two of Dartisans.
We hope to continue these with
your support, so please do
leave some comments on
what worked and what
didn't on our G+ stream.
And as always, join our mailing
list at dartlang.org
and let us know what's working
for you and what you'd like to
see from the Dart platform.
So on behalf of the whole Dart
team, I want to say thank you
to everyone.
And Vijay and Anton, thank you
very much for being our
guests, and congrats on getting
Dartium released.
That is big, and we'll open that
up for downloads, if all
goes well, later today.
VIJAY MENON: Thanks, Seth.
ANTON MUHIN: Thank you.
SETH LADD: All right.
Thanks, everyone.
We'll see you next time.
Bye.